est ce que vous pensez puisqu'on en
parle régulièrement dans la presse
est-ce que vous pensez que la monarchie
représente un avenir pour ces pays là
quand on voit le roi de roumanie qui
essayent de revenir le roi de bulgarie
le roi de yougoslavie le grand duc qui
va à leningrad
je croyais que ça à l'avenir on vous
prouver qu'ils sont encore des séquelles
des scories qui traînent dans la tête
des gens et la connaissance que j'ai
tout le monde sait que rien ne
recommence jamais mais je peux pas
répondre sur ces choses me regarde alors
d'accord
en 1919 le traité de trianon rend son
indépendance à la slovaquie bratislava
s'affranchit de la tutelle tchèque avec
à sa tête car le trois descendants de la
dynastie d'été chaîne qui avait fondé au
9e siècle est un slovaque
car le 3 reste au pouvoir jusqu'en 1938
où il est chassé de son pays par
monseigneur tisot un proche des nazis
l'héritier au trône antonin 1er net en
exil en 1951 à paris où il vit toujours
en cultivant la nostalgie de son pays
oui effectivement mon premier souhait
serait de visiter tout simplement mon
propre pays que je n'ai jamais vue
d'aller à la rencontre des gens tout
simplement un souhait comme quelqu'un
qui est expatrié qui voudraient voir de
la wind vient où sont ses racines
le projet de visite devient affaire
d'état comme à bucarest où michel de
roumanie a été refoulé dès son arrivée
prague refuse d'accorder tout visa à
antonin premier vaclav havel l'a encore
rappelé dans une déclaration le 2
novembre dernier le retour d'antonin
premier représente une réelle menace
pour l'unité tchécoslovaque et une
vision réaliste des faits nous amène à
penser que les sentiments nationalistes
slovaques sont développées par d'anciens
dirigeants communistes monusco pops le
bac a aussi envie d'exister donc d'une
certaine manière ils ont trouvé le
peuple slovaque a trouvé dans le prince
entonna une figure emblématique qui
pourrait servir de porte drapeau
finalement de cette mémoire collective
la famille d'été chaîne incarne la
résistance slovaque toujours vivace
vis-à-vis des tchèques témoins les 14 %
de suffrages recueillis par le parti
monarchiste slovaque aux dernières
élections
même si le prince entonna n'a pas de
projet politique
enfin oui enfin
suis imaginé en quoi maintenant
sérieusement il est un devoir pour moi
au cas où les slovaques le souhaitent de
les aider je veux dire n'importe quel
citoyen le ferai tout comme alexandre de
yougoslavie ou siméon de bulgarie le
prince antonin n'est pas un pouls de
schiste en attendant l'appel de son
peuple il reste simplement d'un bain de
foule parmi les siens le prétendant au
thème de fleuve à qui interdit de séjour
par vaclav havel s de l'info s de
l'intox
jeanne moreau à l'oreille oui cette fois
de jouer charles unique c'est l'info toi
ouais pourquoi je suis pas un si mauvais
qu'ils chantent toujours l'intuition
gauche mais jusqu'à présent ce n'est pas
tellement élevé chez nous
non mais tu continues et continue mais
toi ça je dis que ces défauts si tu dis
que c'est de la faute d'accord tous les
trois mois le jeune moraux que quand
même déjà deux couplets
on nous a dit que c'était la peau tous
les trois pour l'info on écoute l'expert
philippe guère écouté jeanne je crois
qu'on s'achemine directement vers la
compilation des oeuvres de jeanne moreau
à la fin de cette émission seulement
puisque c'est totalement totalement
totalement de l'intox ont applaudi il
fait des sujets
un espoir parmi les trois il n'ya pas
bon bah oui la preuve et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu